Prestad mucha atención a estas sorprendentes
declaraciones de la Primera Ministra de Suecia,
la líder socialdemócrata Magdalena Andersson:
(La PM sueca dice que la integración de inmigrantes
ha fallado y ha alimentado el crimen de bandas
- Reuters)
(La integración ha sido demasiado pobre al
mismo tiempo que hemos tenido una gran inmigración.
La sociedad ha sido demasiado débil, los
recursos para la policía y los servicios
sociales han sido demasiado pobres.
[...] Se ha permitido que la segregación
llegue tan lejos que tenemos sociedades paralelas
en Suecia.
Vivimos en el mismo país pero en realidades
completamente diferentes.”
- Magdalena Andersson, PM de Suecia)
Que una líder socialdemócrata que además
está en el poder haga declaraciones como
esta sobre la inmigración no es algo nada
común.
Algo muy serio tiene que estar pasando en
Suecia, ¿No os parece?
¿A qué se refiere exactamente la Primera
Ministra?
¿Por qué el tema de la inmigración ha pasado
a estar en el candelero en uno de los países
más abiertos del mundo?
¿Qué está pasando exactamente en Suecia?
[Por cierto, antes de seguir un apunte.
¿Te has preguntado alguna vez cómo ganan
dinero y cuánto ganan los grandes gigantes
tecnológicos como Apple, Microsoft, Alphabet
o Amazon?
Ojo que no es una pregunta menor.
Hablamos de empresas cuyo valor combinado
supera los 7,5 billones de dólares, más
de 5 veces el PIB de un país como España?
Hablamos de empresas que han sustituido a
los grandes grupos industriales y petroleros
como las empresas más grandes del mundo.
La pregunta, ¿Cómo lo han conseguido?
Creo que la respuesta puede sorprenderte.
Así que si quieres saber más no te pierdas
el último vídeo de Si lo Hubiera Sabido,
el canal de información financiera de Mutuactivos
con el que participamos.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.]
Dicho esto continuemos.
(CIFRAS DE PÁNICO)
Prestad mucha atención a las siguientes cifras.
Estoy seguro que a más de uno os van a sorprender
y mucho:
En 2021 se registraron en Suecia 335 tiroteos
que se saldaron con 47 personas fallecidas.
Sí, vale, si nos estáis viendo desde Estados
Unidos o América Latina estos números os
pueden parecer una broma.Casi una arcadia
feliz.
Si tenemos en cuenta la diferencia de población,
el dato es infinitamente mejor que el que
cada año registra Estados Unidos o prácticamente
cualquier país latinoamericano.
Por ejemplo, en 2020 tan solo en Estados Unidos
los homicidios y tiroteos le costaron la vida
a más de 23.000 personas.
Hablamos de un escenario completamente diferente.
Sin embargo, para los cánones europeos la
cosa es totalmente distinta.
(Suecia es el país de toda Europa dónde
más están creciendo los crímenes relacionados
con armas de fuego y tiene una de las tasas
de fallecidos más altas.
Por ejemplo, mientras que Suecia tiene una
media de 4 muertes por millón de habitantes
al año por armas de fuego, la media europea
se sitúa en 1,6.
Además a diferencia del resto de Europa la
tendencia en Suecia es creciente.)
Un dato curioso.
Todo esto supone por ejemplo, que la probabilidad
de que un hombre de entre 15 y 29 años reciba
un disparo es 10 veces más alta en Suecia
que en Alemania.
(Suecia a la cabeza en tiroteos mortales en
Europa, según informe.
En menos de una década, Suecia ha superado
a Italia y a los países de Europa del Este
en tener el mayor número de tiroteos mortales
en Europa.
Barrons)
Pero esto no es todo.
En 2019 se registraron 260 delitos con explosivos
en toda Suecia, un incremento del 60% respecto
al año anterior.
Hablamos de bombas y artefactos explosivos
que suelen explotar en espacios públicos,
sobre todo en los exteriores de urbanizaciones
de apartamentos y en pequeños negocios.
¿Sorprendidos?
Pues si a todo esto le sumamos también que
Suecia tiene las tasas de violaciones y violencia
sexual más altas de toda Europa y que, además,
los delitos de odio contra minorias, como
por ejemplo las personas LGTB también están
al alza, entonces tenemos el combo casi perfecto.
Es evidente que en Suecia hay un problema.
Eso sí, sorprendentemente, si nos fijamos
en todos los delitos, la tasa de criminalidad
de Suecia no es particularmente elevada, está
en la media europea.
Es decir, que el país nórdico tiene sobre
todo un problema con las armas, los explosivos,
la violencia sexual y los ataques a minorias.
En el contexto europeo, Suecia tiene fundamentalmente
un problema con los crímenes violentos y
de corte sexual.
Y esto es precisamente lo que explica que
los suecos sean precisamente y por mucho los
europeos que más preocupados están por el
crimen.
Para ellos es la ya pimera preocupación.
Y esto es también lo que explica las palabras
de la Primera Ministra, Magdalena Andersson,
que vimos al comienzo de este vídeo.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto, la pregunta
que seguro, seguro, muchos os estáis haciendo
es:
¿Qué demonios está pasando en Suecia?
¿Qué diablos explica semejante ola de violencia?
Pues bien, la mayoría de los tiroteos y las
explosiones en Suecia tienen que ver con bandas
del crimen organizado.
(En el país nórdico 8 de cada 10 tiroteos
tienen que ver con bandas criminales.
El problema que más inquietud está causando
es que más de la mitad, el 53% de los sentenciados
a prisión nacieron en el extranjero.
Un porcentaje que si tenemos en cuenta tanto
las personas nacidas en el extranjero como
las que pertenecen a una segunda generación
se eleva hasta casi el 90% de los sospechosos
de protagonizar tiroteos.)
Queridos amigos, amigas, lógicamente, con
este vídeo, no pretendemos señalar a nadie
por su origen.
Todo lo contrario.
Sabéis que en VisualPolitik nos gustan cosas
como la libertad de circulación y que pensamos
que los movimientos migratorios son un poderoso
motor de prosperidad…
Siempre y cuándo las cosas se hagan bien.
Por eso con este vídeo queremos poner sobre
la mesa algunos factores que pueden dificultar
una integración efectiva.
Y por eso la situación en Suecia puede ser
radicalmente distinta a la de países como
Australia, Nueva Zelanda o, incluso, Estados
Unidos.
¿Recordáis el titular que veíamos al principio
del vídeo?
(La PM sueca dice que la integración de inmigrantes
ha fallado y ha alimentado el crimen de bandas
- Reuters)
Pues…
Exactamente eso.
Así que para entender toda esta situación
tenemos que hacernos unas cuantas preguntas:
¿De verdad el aumento de los crímenes violentos
en Suecia es sólo culpa de los inmigrantes?
¿Qué responsabilidad tiene aquí el poder
público, los políticos?
¿En qué ha fallado - si es que lo ha hecho
- Suecia?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(¿UNA ÚNICA CULPABLE?)
Amigos, amigas, en Suecia la delincuencia
relacionada con la inmigración tiene un componente
clave a la hora de unir ambos fenómenos:
la exclusión social.
Pero, un momento, antes de qué alguno pongáis
el grito en el cielo, no, no os vamos a contar
la típica historia de que la delincuencia
está justificada exclusivamente por la pobreza
y que la solución es dar muchas más ayudas
y subsidios de todo tipo.
Este es un tema muy complejo, en el que vamos
a poder encontrar muchas causas y en el que
la pobreza juega un papel muy importante.
Pero si algo sobra en Suecia son precisamente
las ayudas y los subsidios públicos.
Y de hecho, aunque pueda resultar contradictorio,
este exceso de fondos públicos puede contribuir
a explicar buena parte de este tsunami de
exclusión y crimen que ha experimentado el
país escandinavo.
Esto es algo que hasta la Primera Ministra
socialdemócrata parece empezar a tener claro.
(En Suecia la población inmigrante recibe
enormes cantidades de ayudas públicas, especialmente
si son solicitantes de asilo.
Pero si hay un subsidio que destaca por encima
del resto es la asignación por hijo, un subsidio
que no es exclusivo para los inmigrantes.
En 1982 cuándo Suecia comenzó a experimentar
tasas muy bajas de natalidad se creó un subsidio
que ofrece suculentos ingresos a las familias
por tener hijos.)
Y no, no hablamos de un cheque bebe al uso.Hablamos
de una subvención que toda persona residente
legal en Suecia cobra desde el mes siguiente
del nacimiento hasta que el niño cumplo los
16 años de edad.
E incluso, bajo ciertas circunstancias, esta
ayuda se puede extender hasta los 20 años.
¿Y qué ofrece el estado sueco por cada hijo?
Pues básicamente una subvención de 1.250
coronas al menos, unos 120 euros o 126 dólares.
Luego, además, de este subsidio hay muchos
otros que favorecen especialmente a las familias
inmigrantes.
Hablamos por ejemplo de las ayudas a los alquileres
para familias numerosas o las ventajas en
el acceso a vivienda pública o los subsidios
directos en el caso de los solicitantes de
asilo, entre muchos otros.
Pero la pregunta que muchos os estaréis haciendo
es, a ver, Alberto; ¿Qué tiene todo esto
de malo?
¿Qué tiene que ver con el problema que estamos
abordando en este vídeo?
Pues, ni más ni menos que todas estas ayudas
tienen consecuencias directas sobre el mercado
laboral.
Digamos que muchas personas terminan haciendo
de las ayudas públicas algo más que un recurso
transitorio.
Y, ojo, no lo decimos nosotros.
Lo dicen, por ejemplo, los datos de empleo.
Y, además, lo dicen claramente.
(La peor parte se la llevan las mujeres, ya
que muchos de estos subsidios desincentivan
su incorporación al mercado laboral y su
integración social, que ya de por sí puede
resultar complicada en algunas culturas.
Por ejemplo, según Eurostat en Suecia la
tasa de empleo de las mujeres nacidas en el
extranjero es casi 20 puntos inferior a la
tasa de las mujeres que han nacido en el país.
Por otro lado, estas ayudas fomentan también
una falsa estabilidad económica que hace
que muchos beneficiarios no busquen trabajos
regulares precisamente para no perder estos
subsidios.
Esto es gasolina para crear redes informales
que terminan favoreciendo la creación y el
desarrollo de grupos criminales y bandas.)
En Estados Unidos y Nueva Zelanda los inmigrantes
tienen tasas de empleo más altas que la población
nacida en el país.
En el caso de Australia y Canadá la diferencia
es de apenas 3,4 y 1,7 puntos porcentuales
respectivamente Pues bien, en Suecia la diferencia
es de casi 15 puntos.
Es decir hablamos de una situación completamente
distinta.
Y eso no es todo.
Al reducir las tasas de empleo y disuadir
a muchos inmigrantes de buscar empleos formales
a tiempo completo, también se reduce su grado
de integración y se merma su contacto con
el resto de la sociedad.
Si a ello le sumamos las políticas de vivienda
pública el resultado es un cóctel perfecto
para la gestación de guetos, un ambiente
particularmente propicio para las bandas.
Se calcula que tan sólo en Estocolmo hay
unas 60 bandas de crimen organizado operando
a lo largo y ancho de la ciudad.
La pregunta es, ¿tiene todo esto solución?
¿Qué consecuencias pueden tener estas políticas?
¿Exactamente qué es lo que quiere hacer
ahora la socialdemócrata Suecia?
Pues, amigos, amigas, como tantas veces las
malas políticas no solo conllevan malos resultados,
en ocasiones también respuestas malas.
O al menos
(DEL BLANCO AL NEGRO SIN RUMBO CLARO
De repente Suecia está cambiando, y lo está
haciendo a pasos acelerados incluso aunque
el gobierno siga en manos de políticos socialdemócratas.
¿Lo está haciendo en la buena dirección?
Bueno, ese ya es otro debate.
El caso es que si hasta hace poco Suecia era
un ejemplo de puertas abiertas, ahora la reacción
social y política puede terminar alimentando
movimientos antagónicos y hostiles hacia
esa realidad..
Por ejemplo, si en 2015, Suecia se convirtió
con diferencia en el país que más refugiados
sirios acogió, en relación a su población
ahora, tan solo 7 años después, los titulares
que podéis encontrar en Google si buscáis
“inmigración” y “Suecia” son bastante
diferentes.
(Incluso Suecia no quiere más inmigrantes
- Foreign Policy)
Ahora, el propio gobierno socialdemócrata
van a poner en marcha una nueva ley de inmigración
supuestamente para atajar la causa de todos
los problemas:
(La nueva Ley de Inmigración sueca endurece
la residencia permanente para refugiados y
visitantes - Euronews)
Con la nueva ley, las personas llegadas del
extranjero ya no tendrán tan fácil acceder
a las ayudas públicas.
Tampoco será posible conseguir un permiso
de trabajo sin tener un contrato.
Y además se requerirá un mínimo de tres
años viviendo en Suecia para conseguir la
residencia permanente y la justificación
de unos ingresos mínimos de 810 euros mensuales.
El objetivo último es que lleguen muchos
menos inmigrantes.
Por supuesto ese no es el problema.
Suecia tiene muchos menos inmigrantes que
países como Australia, Nueva Zelanda o Canadá.
Pero da igual.
Esta es la respuesta que quiere dar el gobierno
socialdemócrata de Magdalena Andersson.
Lo que supone un giro de 180 grados en la
política del país
(Eso sí lo que de momento no cambiará es
el abultado régimen de ayudas y subvenciones.
Ni tampoco las políticas de vivienda para
evitar la formación de guetos.
Más bien todo lo contrario.
El gobierno socialdemócrata de Magdalena
Andersson quiere poner aún más dinero sobre
la mesa sin prestar atención a cuestiones
tan relevantes como el nivel de empleo o emprendimiento
que tienen la población llegada del extranjero.
Dos factores que junto a la educación resultan
claves para promover la integración.)
No nos equivoquemos, el problema no es el
número de inmigrantes que hay en Suecia,
el problema está en el ineficiente e inadecuado
régimen de ayudas y subsidios de todo tipo.
Al final con este tipo de cambios se corre
el riesgo de criminalizar a toda la población
extranjera sin conseguir realmente nada.
Y qué queréis que os diga, qué la respuesta
del gobierno sea reconocer el problema, culpar
a la inmigración, hacer cambios legales para
que lleguen menos extranjeros al país y querer
regar con más dinero a los que ya están
no parece muy sensato, por muchos votos que
las subvenciones puedan darle al gobierno.
El problema de Suecia no son los inmigrantes
ni mucho menos la falta de gasto social.
De hecho en Suecia el gasto social medido
en términos de PIB es, por ejemplo, un 52%
más alto que en Australia.
Lo cierto es que todo apunta a que el problema
es exactamente el contrario.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para tu:
Con todo lo que has visto ¿Crees que el verdadero
problema de Suecia es la inmigración o por
el contrario es más bien el resultado de
unas malas políticas públicas?
Déjanos tu comentario aquí debajo y, si
te ha gustado este vídeo, no olvides darle
like y suscribirte a nuestro canal para no
perder ninguna de las novedades que están
por venir.
Como siempre, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.